police moving in on greenpeace
protesters in rotterdam campaigners with
the environmental pressure groups scaled
this silo belonging to shell as part of
a direct action they also blocked off
part of rotterdam port with this 30
meter boat while smaller vessels played
their parts calling for an end to all
fossil fuel advertising and sponsorship
in europe a new greenpeace report claims
two-thirds of recent social media ads by
the likes of shell and total amounted to
what it calls greenwashing it could
either be advertisement that show
renewable energy even if the renewable
energy constitutes only a very very tiny
percentage of their investments or it
could also be what we would call full
solutions so for instance a promoting
offsetting schemes that will allow you
know to continue driving your car as if
nothing has happened greenpeace is one
of more than 20 groups aiming to get a
million signatures for a petition to the
european commission if they do brussels
must consider passing legislation they
want a ban on advertising that includes
vehicles flights or ferries that run on
fossil fuels but here in the netherlands
it's the oil and gas firms under the
greatest pressure after a case brought
by environmental groups earlier this
year a court ordered royal dutch shell
to cut its global carbon emissions by
the end of 2030 by 45
of 2019 levels and the ruling warned of
an imminent violation of the company's
legal obligations to reduce dangers to
human life which it knew about
shell is appealing against that judgment
but activists hope things like the
petition will push it to act to curb the
growing climate emergency i'm confronted
with it daily i'm confronted with it
when i see the news when i see news
about refugees coming because there's no
possibility to live in their countries i
see it when the oil prices are rising in
england i see it in every day and i
think we should just act
shell says it respects the right to
protest but called this action on its
property unsafe and illegal it also says
it's important it lets customers know
about lower carbon options via
advertising
port authorities say there was barely
any disruption to shipping traffic but
the message has been delivered a call
for europe to act over what big energy
companies claim about their green
credentials nadine barber al jazeera
rotterdam